I also noticed that uh desserts are
different nowadays when I was young
the waiter would come and go what do you
want for dessert cherry pie or apple pie
and you go I will have a cherry pie and
a guy bring them very simple you know
things were very simple back then now
desserts oh my Lord the guy shows up and
he's got a big tray uh Canton angle and
every confection known to man is on it
he's
and I don't like the way he talks like
because he doesn't talk like the pork
chop talk anymore all of a sudden for
the dessert he's like oh the sexual
undertones you know
I mean it's all like ah
why are you saying I like that
may I attempt you with something
tempt me
you're like decadent things right uh
I hope you left some room in your belly
okay listen
are we still talking about desserts here
what the [__]
what's going on
I don't want to end up blowing you in
the bathroom or something
this guy gave me a keychain a plastic
well that guy is a [__]
get the supermodel back hey look 1.99 at
the airport we really gave you a key I
was gonna bring it out but I couldn't
get it off of my keys so I left in the
backstage but it gave me a keychain why
can't you bring out the g-string
I know to smoke I'll smoke it for you I
know no I'm trying to I just figured it
would be rude not to offer you look it's
nice but I'm trying not to and I feel
like I'm sitting there with a cigarette
I feel if I you know I took one puff I
have an oral fixation my doctor tells me
which is not good
how did he know that I was sucking his
[__]
you know me this guy Milo schwarming
yeah he's a big director so he signed me
on Saturday Night Live so he got the
idea I was smart everybody
read the news that just come to that we
go out we'll eat it no boo and see [__]
right and so I go with them so it's me
him and two guys from Fort to foreigners
right and so these guys know everything
you know and uh so they're like ah what
about uh the situation and the Balkans
or something like that yeah you're the
news man and I just kind of play along
like by repeating what they had said
three sentences and uh so anyways he
goes I put you in the movie man I need a
guy to and he was gonna give me a big
part right so I was like no no no don't
do that
and he's like I don't worry about it I
go seriously milosh I don't want you to
give me a big part of you but what do
you want I go just you know give me a
small part that'd be cool so he made me
a reporter right in this in this people
versus Larry Flynt right yes yeah I
played one of the people right so
originally I think it sounds like you
were about to be Larry Flynn right oh my
God damn Larry Flynn so we are going to
uh we do the movie right and uh and I'm
a reporter you know so he goes you know
you drive up and get out of the car and
run in I go well I can't drive
look at a cab will drive you so it
doesn't make sense like a reporter is in
a cab so we do the scene it's me and
Larry Flint you know and me and Woody
Harrelson yeah so that anyways Woody
Harrelson's really cool and [__]
actors man when they're really good it's
like something different right you know
because I'm just I'm just waiting for
the other [__] to stop talking about I
remember you're not even paying
attention no I'm just hoping to remember
my word so anyways uh [__] what's his
name Woody Harrelson asked me if I
wanted beer you know he goes uh you want
a beer I got no it's cool I don't I
don't drink you know he goes you don't
want a beer I go no I don't drink but
thanks man and then I go uh you drink
like uh I thought you just smoke weed
and all that [__] and then uh all of a
sudden Milo schwerman goes cats what the
[__] is going on like we were in the
movie you didn't know yeah
and talking like a regular person
many of you woke up and you realized you
were wrong about everything you just you
just woke up you go God damn I've been
wrong about every single thing I've ever
believed
yeah
it's time to go down to the Rope store
in my opinion because
it's not gonna get better you know
go to the Rope store that's my
suggestion to you
and get a hunk of rope about this big
and then go to the rickety stool store
and listen it's no coincidence that the
Rope store and the rickety stools are I
was right beside each other right
I don't want to get political or
anything like that but
when people commit suicide no one ever
understands you know I mean people
commit suicide people go I don't I don't
understand why and I go you don't
well you live in a cotton candy house or
something what the [__]
you don't know about life
how it only disappoints and
gets worse and worse until it ends in a
catastrophe
the [__]
there's two reasons guys will hang
themselves from the neck one is like we
said to escape this worthless masquerade
of a life we pretend we have
and the second reason we hang ourselves
from the net is to whack up these guys
I don't understand
it's called auto-erotic asphyxiation
it's a big fancy word but it's a filthy
thing
and uh this is my problem with it the
risk reward
it's not good
21 years old he was in a McDonald's
going you want Lids on these
everybody's different but of course sir
it's worse than that no here can you
pick it up Adam yeah sure I'll pick it
up for you no but while you're down
there yeah
you're writing a book yes how to be a
model yes the complete idiot's guide to
getting into modeling so like rule
number one be incredibly beautiful
I mean what are the things that you can
do rule number two yeah don't be a
[__]
are you Jewish yeah okay then you'll get
it oh okay okay half Jewish no I'm full
full Jewish full Jewish all right then
but you're young so you might not get it
maybe okay so here's the joke Holocaust
denier I'm awesome
my father's favorite joke
oh you had a joke uh uh roses are grave
violets are gray tulips are gray because
I am a dog
thank you we first met I met you
underneath the Queensboro Bridge
you at the time were jerking off punks
for 15 a man
grandmother your family doesn't know
that when you were a young man you used
to jerk off punks for 50 knows a man
oh joking aside I know you love to joke
Bob Dole you know but that guy he's a
war hero and you know he gave his his uh
arm for his country you know he went
through all these debilitating injuries
during the war for his country was great
and all fairness so Bill Clinton also he
had a kind of some War injury really
yeah when he was in England there during
the Vietnam War I heard he uh
he had a bad injury he burned his mouth
on a bong really
do you think this would be funny this is
a practical joke if you just wrote a
suicide note and just blamed some random
guy would you think that would be
yeah man
[Applause]
you know like your Barber or something
like that you know
it was all Ralph Abernathy's Falls
and go have you ever heard of a fellow
named a Norm Macdonald yeah I go yeah
you come in every couple of months for a
trim okay well anyways he took his life
because of you
we're already hearing this letter would
you like to keep the
and then Ralph Abernathy would have to
spend the rest of his life walking down
this week in Minneapolis the Minnesota
obesity Center officially opened its
goals to find ways to identify behaviors
that lead to obesity also it's a good
place to meet fat chicks
against spanking yes with children yeah
well unless it's too consenting adults
what about when they get you and then it
hits the back of your balls
I don't think she wants you to tell
everybody it's under Wikipedia oh she's
I think a lot older than 70. yeah that
sounds it looks great that sounds about
right to me 70. no I never I didn't
think of her seven Jesus Christ almighty
when did she break 50. I like her I like
her too she reminds me and she reminds
me of like your old aunt or something
yeah yeah with her funny opinions
you know what I mean the view is about
you [__] what kind of Hannah has
horse [__] is that yeah Friar's Club
Once I never seen a roast or anything
like that Droid but I see I went one
time I love playing poker I had a bit of
a gambling problem for a while and I
couldn't get enough poker games right so
this dude he told me you gotta go to the
Friars Club man there's a big poker game
there right I have to talk to four
people here so so uh so I go to the to
the Friars Club Barbara are you
listening yeah
[Applause]
let's go
so I'm at the promise and they told me
this is great there's this big poker
game right so I go there and there's all
these old dudes there right and they're
all comics for like 50 years ago I don't
know who the hell they are you know and
it's not like famous Comics like Milton
Burrell or anybody like that it's these
B level comics from 50 years ago you
know like a Freddie Roman and dudes like
that right so they're all playing poker
you know they're out playing poker and
I'm playing poker I just want to play
poker but they're all like making jokes
you know and every joke they're making
involves me being a gay dude
here's a you know be like a queen I'd
get a queen
for the lady
[Music]
and they don't laugh you know and I
didn't notice at first I'm just playing
cards and all of a sudden I realize
every joke is me being a homosexual man
right so I'm not a homosexual man as you
well no
[Applause]
he's definitely not you're not oh yeah
but let me tell you something else yeah
I would have sex with you while you were
awake
yeah
okay
[Applause]
you've got your novelty for me
and then I'm playing and then all of a
sudden this old dude next to me goes ah
kid just uh you gotta you gotta show him
uh show them What You're Made Of You
insult them too you know so I'm like oh
so there's an old dude there's like 70
years old so I go hey uh they're old
dude you probably I've had a few guys
I've had sex with a few guys right he
goes
when you're writing you'll learn a lot
of that I went to a guy who's a big
writer guy who told me about things I
didn't know about metaphors you remember
them
said you got to use metaphors I mean
what's that
he's like that's a thing so metaphor is
like you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make a drink so I'm like what
the [__] does that mean so he's like
that means you can take a person you
know and you can give them all the
information and everything but he still
has to be the one to absorb it himself
so I was like well why the [__] didn't
you just say that like what
why do you have to put a horse into it
like what
you thought I was so stupid you need to
make it into some Fable like what
a horse the nation is still reeling from
Thursday's bombshell announcement that
Lisa Marie Presley has filed for divorce
from Michael Jackson according to
friends the two were never a good match
she's more of a stay-at-home type and
he's more of a homosexual pedophile
[Applause]
yeah
in an effort to raise money for his
enormous legal bills O.J Simpson this
week began marketing a video which
attempts to prove his innocence should
the tape not sell Simpson has a backup
idea his very own video of the actual
murders themselves
well let's get to OJ O.J Simpson's
lawyers say they don't want the families
of Nicole Brown and Ronald Goldman in
the courtroom during the trial they're
afraid the presence of the family
members will just remind OJ of how much
more killing he still has to do
all right
according to a survey 58 of men would
have sex with a woman they disliked
although while having sex they would
really really like them and then
afterwards not like them again
in a recent interview Christy Brinkley
suggested that football players should
have special gloves connected to lights
on their helmets that way when they
catch the ball you'll know who has
possession
read these and other interesting ideas
in Christie's new book I'm an idiot
well in a sworn deposition this week O.J
Simpson claimed that he never ever beat
choked or hit his ex-wife with a closed
or open fist luckily for O.J lawyers
forgot to ask if he'd ever cut her head
off
well in a recent interview Christopher
Reeve said that Robin Williams comedy
helped convince him to go on living he
then added that Paulie Shores comedy
made him pray for the sweet release that
death would bring
and the pope came out with a book this
week which contains a series of essays
examining faith and morality in today's
secular world and the changing role of
the Catholic Church as it approaches the
21st century the book is entitled God
himself told me that O.J is guilty
King of Pop Michael Jackson who
collapsed during rehearsals for a
concert last week has been released from
the hospital doctors say his condition
is stable and continues to improve
although he is still a freak
thank you
well O.J Simpson's lawyer stopped
feuding this week finally the Dream Team
F Lee Bailey and Robert Shapiro were
able to put aside their differences and
express their admiration for each other
after O.J threatened to cut their heads
off
[Applause]
in an interview out this week
Demi Moore says she would like to have
another baby this time a boy to go along
with her three daughters and two huge
breasts foreign
[Applause]
audience Yoko Ono shocked the crowd by
tearing up a Bible most shocking of all
Yoko Ono performed to a packed audience
well according to published reports
Michael Jackson's wife is now pregnant
with the pop star's second child asked
why he decided to become a father again
so soon Jackson explained that his
seven-month-old son is starting to lose
his looks
and in Boise the Idaho State Medical
Board has censored Dr Levar Withers
after dozens of women allege that he
fondled them while their legs were up in
stirrups an angry Dr Withers replied hey
if I'm such a monster why didn't they
just go to another dentist
[Applause]
three years ago an 11 year old British
school girl put a message in a bottle
and tossed it into the Atlantic Ocean
well this week she was astounded to
receive a reply from Halfway Around the
World sadly the reply read you're 11
what are you wearing
on Friday the juice officially endorsed
Bill Clinton for president adding adding
quote I'd like to help him any way I can
to which the president replied
well there is one thing
20th Century Fox has announced that
Macaulay Culkin will not be hired to
star in Home Alone 3.
Studio spokesman said that it was
nothing personal but with Culkin now 16
years of age the only way to keep him in
the film would be to make the character
[__]
well there may be trouble in Paradise
Lisa Marie Presley confirmed this week
that she and Michael Jackson live in
separate residences 50 miles away from
each other Lisa Marie was quoted as
saying I guess being married to a
homosexual pedophile wasn't such a great
idea after that
[Applause]
in an effort to feel smarter than
somebody Dan Quayle this week spoke to 4
000 Amway employees
[Applause]
[Music]
President Clinton up here on crutches
making a speech I mean I thought that
was just amazing you know I mean it's
been difficult for the president you
know he can't jog now and he needs help
getting around and he's still you know
he's still uh occasionally suffers great
pain you know on the upside you got your
medical marijuana so that's uh you know
you must inhale sir it's the only way
you're going to get better it's
[Applause]
yeah he says he was from the farm you
know and he says a a guy a guy comes
from the city city slicker comes and he
buys a a farm and the farmer next door
comes over to him says hey now uh would
you like to come over to my house
tonight we're going to have a big Shin
dig for you uh because you know we're
neighborly here in the city guys well
this is something that's I really like
you know that this is why I moved to the
farm to have things like this you know
guy says it'll be a hell of a big party
you know he goes it'll be you know a
little a little drinking little fighting
little [__] you know and the guy City
guy goes well that sounds good what time
should I be here and the farmer goes
anytime you like just the two of us
thank you
so they would drink
then get in a fight
then [__]
it's your dad's favorite that's my dad's
favorite joke there's Charles Woodson
how about that I want a season here
[Applause]
great Manny he became the first
defensive player to win the Heisman
Trophy and congratulations Charles that
is something that no one can ever take
away from you unless you kill your wife
and a waiter in which case
desert
just a word of advice
I came here from Las Vegas Nevada and
what was that an air
where do airplanes go from airports
I was in the airport guys were asking
everyone my ID and it occurred to me
that ID is a strange abbreviation
because I is short for I and then d
assured for identification so
seems to me D is doing most of the
leg work on that one something people
don't know about you I'm deeply closeted
gay guy
no kidding well I'm not coming out
though
wait a minute
what are you revealing here today I'm
I'm not revealing anything I'm saying
I'm deeply closeted
well that means you're gay
I wouldn't say that why would I say that
I'm deeply closeted
no but I that means you're very very gay
but you don't want to come out you're so
closeted that I refuse to say I'm gay
right
exactly but that doesn't that mean
you're gay hey hey easy buddy
there's this movie coming out yes yes
title undetermined at this point
chairman of the board wow all right do
something with that you freak
and
I I bet the board is spelled b-o-r-e-d
foreign
like eight years old and I was behind my
garage I was sneaking a cigarette back
there and my dad caught me I'll never
forget it his big head came around the
corner of the grass there was my dad's
big head
and then his body right after it there's
his body
trailing his head as it often would
and he grabbed me and he hauled me in
and I thought I was in with a strapping
in my life you know what it is he put
out his giant cigar
less than half the size of my arm this
big cigar stuck in my mouth lit It Up
made me smoke it all the way through
right to the end
that's when I started smoking cigars
real heavy
I have planned backfired on him
and there was another time I remember
now that I'm thinking about it I was
behind the garage again as luck would
have it and uh this time I was smoking a
big fat joint back there
don't do drugs
and uh
my dad's big head showed up again
and there's no body this time just a big
head
that was the funny part
you like to mix it up like that you know
so anyways he grabbed me there with his
teeth and he hauled me in and uh I
thought I was there with a strapping of
my life you know but uh injecting me
with Heroin
size it was a strict man I'll tell you
that
but you gotta quit smoking that's all I
know man you got a Christmas not all I
know I know other things too but uh be a
kind of a wasted life if that's all they
combed out of a dare but
you gotta quit smokers otherwise you get
old and then unhealthy you know you see
a lot of that you know oh some guys
don't you ever see those old guys
doesn't matter what the hell they do to
themselves they just grow old anyway you
know meet a guy video all this bastard
you ever made you know just does
everything wrong you know every day I
smoke pork backstage cigarettes I drink
a bottle of Jack Daniels and I hit
myself in the head with a shovel every
goddamn
I'd like to die
God I'd love to die
one time I put a shotgun in my mouth
feel the whole goddamn back in my head
out there
slide ringing in the ears
I can't die I met in the airport I met
Matlock oh Matlock is uh Andy Griffin
yeah and he used to call himself Andy
Griffin now he goes by Ben Matlock
really calls himself Ben Matlock but uh
so uh yeah I went into the airport and
he was in there and you know the
bookstores they have and the in the
airport yeah sure so he's in there he's
reading a big one in big thick books you
know how smart yeah you know
so I'm staying over there look I'm
leafing through a Jughead comic I see
him over there
so I think to myself I say hey I'm going
to sidel up beside uh old Ben Matlock
yeah and I'm going to grab one in big
books myself he didn't have to know
nothing sure pretty soon we get in a
conversation we start talking and uh and
I I find out how he ever saw that case
where clad uh Claude Akins killed you
remember anyways whatever I wanted to
talk right so uh take 10 minutes I'm
talking to him I'm talking to him he's
very friendly very outgoing and
everything like that and it was really
nice then all of a sudden I realized
it wasn't Ben Matlock at all really
it's not Andy Griffith yeah just some
old man and uh
now don't you think that this guy has a
moral you know a responsibility to tell
people instantly that he's not I don't
know that's a good question I never
thought of that
yeah what else I like about the magic
phone Wikipedia
oh you ever use that that's the best man
it makes a democracy out of smartness
everybody's equal now you know used to
be a guy go to school five six years and
then he talks to me and I'd be like ah
but now
now it's all different
I got my magic phone in my pocket
so a guy will say to me he'll go hey
Norm you ever hear of a fella that went
by the name of Claude Monet
and I go why of course I have I gotta go
to the bathroom
and I go to the bathroom and I'm in
there 20 25 minutes and I come back
I go Hey listen uh I was just uh we were
talking about Claude Monet and I just
want to say that you know what I liked
about him was uh his paintings
he was a painter and I loved how he used
the paint
to make paintings
and the guy goes God damn Norm
been able to stamp you into
ah thank you very much ah you're very
kind you know in the uh what's that
I don't know no you're absolutely right
that is my name you know when the people
when the people here asked me to do the
show you know I gotta say I felt kind of
weird you know I don't know if you
remember this but I used to actually be
on this show you know I used to do the
Weekend Update news routine you remember
that and uh yeah
that's where I did the make-believe news
jokes you know that was me right so then
a year and a half ago right I had a sort
of a disagreement with the management at
uh at the NBC uh I wanted to keep my job
right
and they felt the exact opposite
so
so you see they like they fired me
because they said that I wasn't funny
you know now now with most jobs I could
have had a hell of a lawsuit on my hands
for that but but see this is a comedy
show so they got me you know you know
what
you know
but now this is a weird part right it's
only a year and a half later and now
they asked me to host the show
so I wondered I go hey wait a second
here hey
I don't know how did I go in a year and
a half
from being not funny enough to be even
allowed in the building
to being so funny that I'm now hosting
the show
how did I suddenly get so damn funny
thank you
it was inexplicable to me because a year
and a half let's face is not enough time
for a dude to learn how to be fun
then it occurred to me I haven't gotten
funnier the show has gotten really bad
[Applause]
so yeah I'm funny compared to you know
how well you'll see later but
[Applause]
okay so let's recap
the bad news is
I'm still not funny
the good news is the show blows
all right folks we got a bad show for
you tonight Dr Dre Snoop Doggy Dog and
Eminem are here
who are safer drivers men or women well
according to a new survey 55 percent of
adults feel that women are most
responsible for minor fender benders
while 78 blame men for most fatal
crashes please note that the percentages
in these pie graphs do not add up to 100
because the math was done by a woman
of you hissing at that joke it should be
a noted that that joke was written by a
woman so now you don't know what the
hell to do today
foreign
[Applause]
thank you